not that long ago we didn't understand
why we got sick there was no internet
and doctors were basically guessing but
then in the 19th century a few
scientists figured it out
germs one of the scientists was Louis
Pasteur the milk already pasteurized is
piped into this filling station his name
might ring a bell because he developed
pasteurization a process that kills off
germs and things like milk
Louis Pasteur was an accomplished French
chemist when he started to investigate
the causes of disease he developed some
of the earliest vaccines including one
that virtually saved Europe's chicken
industry and his microbiology research
also revived Frances silk production and
his work on pasteurization saved the
French beer and wine industries Pastore
had become a science rock star one of
the key moments in persuading the world
that germs cause disease occurred on a
French form in 1881 Pasteur got into an
argument with a veterinarian who
absolutely refused to accept that germs
might cause anthrax Pasteur basically
challenged him to a scientific duel
you had fifty sheep perfectly healthy
set aside 25 of them given an anthrax
vaccine the other 25 didn't get an
objective
not long after all 50 sheep were
injected with a particularly virulent
strain this was huge especially because
press from around the world came to
cover the results and the reveal was
pretty remarkable the 25 sheep that had
passed those experimental vaccine were
healthy
the others were dying clearly of anthrax
and this was splashed on the front pages
of newspapers across the world Pasteur
was a master for PR but it was necessary
for people to fundamentally alter the
way they fought about infectious disease
to realize that microorganisms were
indeed the cause one really important
outcome of the German Revolution was the
development of more vaccines many
infectious diseases can be brought
completely under control
the had been small pox vaccines they've
been available for well over a century
but that was it as a result of the work
of people like you a pastor you started
to see vaccines introduced for anthrax
for cholera and for typhoid one of the
most important public health innovations
was the introduction of what was called
pasteurization you repeat on a substance
like milk kill off the bacteria and then
it could be solved
it dramatically reduced the number of
children who are dying from
gastrointestinal illness
in fact in the 19th century one out of
every four infants passed away before
the first birthday due to infectious
diseases after the rise of germ theory
and processes like pasteurization the
number of infant mortalities dropped in
some places as much as 50% just over a
hundred years since that day on the
French sheep farm
pasteurization became law in the United
States and in the decades in between
more vaccines were developed including
Louis Pasteur as vaccine for rabies
medicine had paid ineffective for voted
the entirety of human history and how
they were going down the right path so
curative medicine came of age loyalty
because doctors knew what actually
causes disease
[Music]
[Music]
you